nous avons entré s'il vous plaît merci
alors là vous allez voir là c'est
l'entrée de la maison l'entrée est
électrique c'est magnifique et en fait
vous allez voir tout est arboré il y a
une végétation vraiment luxuriante vous
allez adorer et vous allez voir ce qu'a
fait le propriétaire c'est vraiment
génial il a mis ce qu'on appelle des
graviers de Madagascar qui permet quand
on passe sur la route de ne pas entendre
le bruit du gravier donc c'est la
sensation du gravier sans le bruit du
gavier c'est du gravier de Madagascar il
y en a que deux comme ça dans le monde
il y en a une ici une autre à Madagascar
ensuite alors on a on va entrer dans le
hall d'entrée je vais vous demander de
bien vouloir me suivre alors le hall
d'entrée alors ça ça c'est un bambou du
Guatemala
sur un zizi
c'est magnifique et là voilà alors à
côté vous voyez donc l'entrée donc là
vous rentrez et là tout de suite il y a
un escalier qui va donner aux chambres
vous allez voir c'est magnifique et là
tout de suite vous voyez alors on est
exposé sud-ouest Nord
c'est à dire que le soleil vraiment
entre dans la maison toute la journée
c'est magnifique regardez après vous
allez rentrer dans un beau salon
regardez le salon alors le salon c'est
ce qu'on appelle alors là vous voyez
comme vous pouvez voir c'est des
fenêtres du Nicaragua c'est magnifique
c'est regarder alors ça a été fait par
terre de fenêtres terre de fenêtres
c'est une société qui utilise la
photosynthèse pour que le bois soit
encore plus vraiment regardé vous voyez
comme le bois le bois est soyeux voilà
donc là c'est alors il il y en a qui me
disent que le salon est un petit peu
étroit voilà c'est ce qu'on dit la
cheminée l'origine la cheminée d'origine
la cheminée d'origine
alors il y a une petite salle à manger
également voilà je vais vous dire la
vérité des gars de ce que je vois pas
ouf c'est pas ouf
ouais le salon est derrière exactement
on dirait Macron c'est le meilleur moyen
alors je vous le dis je vous le dis ça
et ça ce genre de maison de 2200 mètres
carrés c'est le meilleur moyen de perdre
ses amis
n'achetez pas les chéris acheter pas
acheter petit au moins on est serré on
est bien tu amènes une meuf même là-bas
tu sais même pas tu la perds au bout de
2 minutes non mais c'est vrai tu la
cherche partout Daniel tu es où bordel
comment tu fais tu la perds dans la
maison tu es mort alors il y a la salle
de bain la salle de bain est pas mal ah
salle de bain est pas mal alors ça c'est
du marbre du Pérou mais je m'ennuie il a
été fait par un mec qui se vend de la
flûte de pont euh et qui s'est mis dans
le marbre c'est non mais je vous dis
c'est extraordinaire
avec la fontaine moi j'adore les
fontaines ah c'est bon j'adore les
fontaines même Laurent
et ouais c'est très beau alors ça c'est
l'arrière de la maison
c'est très persan non j'ai l'impression
que c'est traversant
il y a une petite terrasse voilà et
alors vous voulez tous voir la piscine
elle est pas nul mais à 80 bars
franchement je suis un petit peu déçu
non mais c'est quoi cette piscine
magnifique
une piscine comme ça 80 millions non
mais moi je veux une piscine moi c'est à
quoi boulevard une piscine à 80 millions
frère il y a des vagues il y a des gars
qui sautent dedans
non mais tu es fou quoi il y a des
dauphins il a raison mais 80 mars frère
bon il y a un cours de tennis alors je
lui dis le tennis Albine total le gars
est complètement admin il y a plus un
gars qui fait du tennis c'est pas
dommage donc voilà donc ça voilà je
distingue
voilà je lui en donne j'en donne 500000
et je prends la maison terminé voilà
comme ça ce sera fait non mais attends
ça va il faut acheter
la partenaire Robbie Williams
35 millions et ouais
on peut la revendre à 88 si l'avant en
88 tu sais quoi
tu vas voir ce que je fais attention et
je t'explique jamais de la vie dans la
88 tu connais l'immobilier je peux te
dire que ça ça vaut pas 88 bars
non franchement ça sent mauvais
45 50 voilà ah oui
double presque
ils se disent on va toujours trouver un
pigeon il pense qu'à Gilles Verdez qui
va revenir avec Faton je veux cette
maison
arrêtez un peu là les mecs arrêtez un
peu Gilles ressaisis-toi mon bébé il y a
un an et là il est en train de la vendre
et ça va marcher c'est le terrain le
plus vaste tout le monde le veut par
exemple vous verrez alors Paris alors
c'est vrai que là-bas ça chute un peu
l'immobilier tu connais très bien si
vous voulez en parler encore vous pouvez
parier comme hier
tu sais quoi la différence tu me la
donnes
en 70 tu dois 18 ans
je te le dis voilà je te le dis suivant
vos 88 je te dois 88 jamais bon à 88
millions d'euros de quoi on parle non
mais 88 millions d'euros
pour savoir que ça ça vaut 80 40
on en a rien à en fait tu
m'aurais dit à vos douches que moi
j'imagine une maison à 80 millions mais
il va falloir rempli
de toute façon toi tu vas même un truc à
200000 tu le vends pas compte
franchement je vais vous dire la vérité
franchement ça sert à rien ce qui est
étonnant à ce prix là c'est que les
oliviers remarqueraient ils sont maigres
il y en a 12 ils ont 12
ce qui vaut le coup quand on a du fric
c'est d'acheter un olivier centenaire ça
c'est bon ils sont pas centenaires comme
ça tout de suite
spécialiste de l'olive
chez toi pardon
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas entendu
les gars on vient il a des oliviers
centenaires chez lui
il a acheté combien non parce que c'est
le voyage tu as des oliviers centenaires
pourquoi tu les présentes pas Daniel
à la maison déjà
dans la maison 50000 balles quoi 50000
balles et si je te prends 4
je te prends 4 livres moi c'est tout ça
vaut combien cette histoire non ça vaut
6 8000 balles
tu as plus qu'un Olivier
je vais compter les oliviers je vais
mettre une photo sur Instagram
[Rires]
tout le monde croit à la maison
en vérité comme j'ai d'Olivier dans la
10e
[Musique]
à 3 tiramisu il y a des trois ça va
jamais en trois il y en a quatre ou six
ne ment pas s'il te plaît tu veux venir
voir je te dis ça va chez moi
comme toi